i wanted to google image it and get a
visual but i don't remember the name of
the show because all i heard was
and i'm like i don't know what words you
actually said yeah
so nina what is the forgotten kids show
that you think deserves its own
cinematic universe
uh thanks for asking brian so i am a
child i'm a child of the 90s i watched a
lot of
rugrats and like early you know
nickelodeon programming there was one
show that i really loved when i was a
kid and
it kind of became
um
a cinematic
universe or at least movie but by a
different name and i'm here to to defend
its honor and the show is 1994's ah real
monsters which oh yeah that's a good
chance and a real monster's walk to the
monsters inc could run it's the same
premise made
way beforehand so it's three monsters
who live in the sewers and go to school
to learn how to scare kids and their can
i see if i remember their names you i
you certainly can and i would i'm gonna
send you guys a picture and i want you
to tell me which one is which um and i
actually i remembered which one was
which which just goes to show like i
can't retain any new information but i
still know this so that's cool i think i
know these okay i'm coming at this as
somebody that like i didn't have cable
growing up so um so this is all new to
you okay cool i love that tom why don't
you guess first why don't you guess
their names first and then i'll come in
and rescue you yeah yeah i want to hear
what you think their names are tom
because this is going to be good
yeah yeah okay so in the middle i'm
going to say joe pesci from casino
to the right
let's say his name is larry
gibbelman and then up top is uh splurnk
you know you're not too far off with
that last one no you're not
surprised surprisingly your biggest your
biggest uh stumble is that you gave them
first and last names and they only have
one name each this is that's right i
think my biggest stumble is that splurk
is going to turn out to be like danish
for
a really
really bad word
so the one in the middle is ickis
the one on the right is crumb yes
and the one on top is oblina that's
correct yes and it's beautiful their
teacher was the gromble yes by the
legendary tim curry yes actually no uh
tim curry voiced the grumble's assistant
i'm just looking up his name zimbo no
yeah the grumble was greg berger with
whom i am
less familiar he seems to be mostly a
voice actor
okay we're gonna
i don't know i'm gonna look this up
right now i'm getting i'm gonna look
this up right now from the internet's
resources we're gonna wikipedia
so it's
working you guys argue
right here
i'm gonna do a pitch for greg burgers
we're gonna pause the show pause
[Music]
okay we're on pausing yeah i mean the
internet says mm-hmm all right well it's
all the greg oh growing boy needs greg
i've derailed all of it and i'm sorry
because i really thought tim curry
voiced the gromball but tim curry was
involved in the show
pretty pretty heavily actually this show
was great i do remember that they they
adopted a dog once named pustule yeah
i forgot about puzzle the whole song it
was and it only ran for i think it was
like 50 like 52 episodes or something it
was really short yeah 52 episodes four
seasons and it's by the same people who
did rugrats but it never got the love
that rugrats did probably because
rugrats was about cute babies and this
was about
disgusting
but then years later you have the you
have crumb in the form of mike wazowski
and i'm not saying pixar stole it but
i'm also not not saying that things are
stolen yeah there's there are definitely
some similarities yeah they're they're
these monsters went to school to learn
how to scare
yeah yeah it's basically monster it's
monsters it's monsters university
exactly what it is but also mike
wazowski like except that he has one
giant eye instead of holding his
eyeballs there's some crumb dna to be
found in there i would argue like the
shorts
or pit hair yeah so yeah i would love to
see
this make a comeback with an animated
movie and a whole universe because
there's got to be more
real monsters where these three came
from and i want to see what else is out
there
and uh yeah
i don't think it got the love it
deserved making those three into like
photo realistic cgi monsters would i
think that that's what the next
generation of kids needs i feel like
their world isn't terrifying enough yeah
you know what that's a great idea let's
make like a polar express style uncanny
valley
computer generation
real monsters
yeah i mean the the creature designs are
are truly they are like if you were to
apply that to
anything outside the realm of animation
they would be truly great they would be
horrifying but
but drawn they're funny to their benefit
yes like crumb is funny like he sleeps
with his eyeballs in a water glass and
he loses them all the time like he's
constantly losing his eyes yeah it's
it's like and yeah they're all really
funny and their animations are really
clever and it's also like the dude from
pan's labyrinth oh my god with that
yeah yeah yeah basically real monsters
is the genesis for so much great art and
it it deserves i mean if you think about
it if you think about a real monster's
cinematic universe or at least a
live-action movie and you use mostly
practical effects yeah who would that be
it would be awesome i would definitely
go see that and it would it would be
such a nostalgia thing for kids who
because this i think it was probably
paired with rugrats i mean it must have
been in the same block because like i
was sitting there watching it and so you
know everyone who was like you know four
five six at that time remembers that
show
it's it was
it was ahead of its time in middle
school yeah so i
know i watched it anyway because i had
nothing else going on that's okay i
watched a lot of degrassi the next
generation in high school instead of
having friends
there you go yeah yeah but i'll try
anyway that's my pick it's all real
monsters
that's a good pick thank you i had two
two that i thought of and one i've
settled on the first one that i'm so
excited i wanted to talk about but i've
decided i'll just mention it was a show
called centurions do either of you know
centurions i don't know that one
centurions is a show all of my pick both
of my picks are from the 80s um because
i am a child of the 80s and um don't
call yourself a child
i'm still a child uh centurions was
basically these three military dudes on
a special super team and they were like
these body suits with holes in them that
you could plug different weapons into
they were awesome that's really cool
basically there was there was an air guy
uh a land guy and a sea guy and they got
their weapons beamed down to them from a
satellite in space and they would fight
bad guys and it was cool that sounds
awesome it was fun it was really cool
but that's not the one i picked the one
i picked is even more obscure and it's
called bionic six do either of you know
bionic six no
all right it's from 1986 it was i
believe originally conceived of as an
animated sequel spin-off to
the six million dollar man and the
bionic woman okay but they
they scrapped that connection but still
made it so that so basically um the
premise is that there's a there's a
super secret bionic guy named bionic one
he goes on adventures he also happens to
be a family man who has a wife and two
children and two adopted children um and
they're all on a ski trip one day and
there's a horrible accident
um
oh my god they're supposed to yeah
they're exposed to the whole family
radiation
to radiation from an alien spaceship and
that's different i thought you meant
like a skiing accident yeah me too i
mean there's an avalanche as well
there's an avalanche as well wow it's
not good for anything so they're all
comatose and so bionic one is like hey
doc let's use bionics and so they all
get bionic
implants and they all get super powers
and they're a crime fighting adventuring
team known as the bionic six there's
there's dad who's bionic one he's like
got super strength they just have
numbers
they're all one they're all bionic one
or whatever so the mom is mother one
she has like
psychic abilities they're all super
strong there's sport one he's one of the
kids he uses a baseball bat and hits
things uh there's rock one
so they started with the name bionic one
yeah and then they're like what's the
most simple way to keep this theme going
yeah let's keep the number one yeah
it's better than bionic one through six
if you think about packaging that's what
i thought you were gonna say yes that
that would make no logical sense
if you were running like a team of
bionic super soldiers right but they're
a family and you don't want any one of
the kids to be like oh he's four i'm
five you like him better than me no you
each get your own code names well but
was one of them sporting another like
dork or loser or something that like
made it clear that well kind of so
wonderful look guys
machines yeah so there's so there's two
biological kids and there's two adopted
kids yeah so the two biological kids are
sport one and rock one and she has rock
one has little speakers on her shoulders
and she blasts sonic blasts and she can
run really fast and she loves shopping
because it was the 80s girls love
shopping then it gets dicey now here's
the part where
you remember it's the 80s
things were it was a simpler time it was
a more reductive time
it's not it's not so
it's not necessarily offensive but it is
not not offensive so they have an asian
foster son who goes by karate one that's
not the best um
that's the big that's the big one where
they're like
he's an asian foster son and he's good
at martial arts it's like guys it's more
than that but it is he was like he's
good at martial arts like if he hadn't
been that would have been so much worse
it seems
sucks at karate yeah
and then they have and they and um and
they have a uh a black uh adopted son as
well and he goes by iq he's super duper
smart he has a um i think a robot named
fluffy and they all hang out they all
fight crime they're all super strong and
it's great not funny what i'm gonna do
well why is
it's an acronym for something i don't
know in the uh in in the chat earlier
you were saying that you were really
excited about one of them that you you
had liked when you were is this the one
you were talking about this is it i
remember watching this as a child i had
one of the action figures for some
reason i was four or five years old and
it was just the coolest show the
animation's amazing
it's just this there it's basically
power rangers before it's power rangers
they all have secret identities and
they're a family and they get along and
they have a good time and they go on
adventures and i love it the bad guys
and if you were if you were to make a
live-action version of this or revive it
today
you could easily spin this off into so
many different movies because you're in
the you're in a a near future kind of
life uh
style going on here but it's also got
like these 80s trapping so it's like
the future filtered through the 80s so
you can have a lot of fun stylistically
with that in terms of your writing and
your your costumes and everything think
stranger things but like in the future i
don't know i don't know what i'm talking
about hold on brian it's just yeah did
pixar also rip off your choice
did they what about the incredibles
uh no no yeah for that pixar ripped off
the fantastic that's true
i was just thinking like superhero
family they all have different powers
they fight crime
yeah it's kind of it's similar in that
way too because the the essential appeal
of that show too is that we're going
it's got this retro future style yeah
there's robots but it feels like it's
the 60s right um
it's just like it's just a good time
it's a good concept and i feel like you
could do bionic sticks unstuck in time
in that same way right like have really
futuristic stuff and really retro stuff
yeah and it's the kind of thing too
where once you open up the idea that
like oh yeah you could just get bionics
now yeah i go to albert einstein high
school
we have a flying minivan they have a
flying minivan like all of this could
make for a really fun
movie and then you open that up to what
other concepts can exist in this world
right so
you know a whole cinematic universe
maybe maybe not but at the very least a
pretty good live-action franchise that i
think has a lot of potential that to me
the bionic six is one of those like
for like things that are in the back of
my mind that every time i remember it
exists i get like really happy right and
then just i was just rewatching before
our chat i was like
this not only
is pretty good but it totally holds up
like it's better than i thought right it
was it's still like you know
kind of junky but it's still it's like
it's better than you think it is so the
bionic verse
the bionic verse and the tragedy is that
you can't like easily watch it unless
you track down awful like crappy
uprights on youtube so
if you can find a way to watch bionic
six go for it um kids tv from back in
the day so yeah
that's me awesome bionic six
thank you i like it everyone watch it
tom
what forgotten kids show
do you think would make a great
cinematic universe okay so i i had two
uh they're they're both uh 90s products
uh the first one i say semi i
i don't know how seriously but big bad
beetle borgs are we all familiar with
the big bad beatleborgs i'm not i am
familiar tangentially they were a
uh a derivative of the power rangers
basically thank you very much i bring up
big bad beatleborgs on a lot of first
dates and you would be surprised how
many people
leave and pretend that they don't know
what i'm talking about it's it was a
great so
yeah so the 90s uh brought the the power
rangers and the whole idea of let's take
shows from japan let's take the the
fight footage that hopefully has a bunch
of people covered
so you can't tell yeah and then insert
that into
astonishingly cheaply shot children's
television shows amazing and just kind
of right around it
uh what i love about big bad beatlebooks
is that everything about it
it's it's this mishmash of like kirkland
signature brand versions of other stuff
so you've got like
yeah i know where you've got this yeah
so you've got the knockoff power rangers
who are three kids who get superpowers
and get they get to turn into
beetle-based power rangers basically
okay they can only do this because they
get sent into a haunted mansion sure
on a dare
uh and they accidentally wake up a
he's called a phasm his name's flabber
and he's he's very much he's a cheap
knockoff of the genie from aladdin but
by way of what do kids love the most jay
leno they love
[Laughter]
problematic late night contract deals
and yeah no so they also
they get super powers from the uh the
haunted house is also full of this is
the weird one it's full of like
universal movie monsters
by their very nature pretty
they're already royalty free yeah but
for some reason they decided to to give
them all just like slight variations on
the name in case
it's like it's the kind of karloff came
after them yeah it's the kind of vampire
that you call a dracula instead of oh oh
oh oh
that's a dracula oh yeah this is awesome
is his name
there's there's mom's the mummy there's
uh
freaking okay i was like what's the
frankenstein oh well that's at least a
little closer what's the frankenstein's
monster called actually hilarious yeah
yep
yes no it's frankin being sponsored it's
and uh
anyway the show's banana uh uh there's a
uh there's a motorcycle writing grandma
that like get
absolute shades of like the the trauma
movie uh
surf nazis must die like it's it's just
it's all of the cheapest versions of
other things
piled into this show i wanted to google
image it and get a visual but i don't
remember the name of the show because
all i heard was
and i'm like i don't know what words you
actually said yeah
it's the spin-off show that they made
from mel blanc's character from the old
buck rogers it's called bdb might as
well be beady beady that's what i said
bad beetle board thanks okay
sorry was it big bad beetle borgs it was
big bad beetle boys until the second
season when it was beatleboy's metallics
uh at which point they had to switch
over to a different show because they
ran out of footage yeah
right oh i just found flabber he's cute
the youtube channel toy galaxy has a
really great video all about big bad
beatleborg so if you haven't seen it i
suggest and they have a great video
about bionic six as well so that's a
really good channel that if anyone is
watching and is interested in
the nonsense we're spewing that's a good
place to go
i'm so glad that you brought that up
because that uh you're right they do
they they do great work or that's the
same place where i found out about my my
actual pick uh wasn't your actual point
no no that was just my initial thought
my actual
there was a show it lasted for one
episode it was in 1992. it's called the
defenders of dynatron senders of
dynatron city yes i had the comic book
when i was this is the weirdest thing i
was on vacation with my family in
florida
and we were at a grocery store for some
reason i guess getting groceries i was
eight years old and my mom let me get
two comic books one was a married with
children comic book i don't know why and
the other one was defenders of dinotron
city and i read it and i read it and i
read it and i was like there's something
significant what is this why is this a
thing this feels like there's something
large going on here but
there wasn't there never was tom explain
what defenders of dynatron city i just
looked this up and
wow yeah amazing yeah so it was created
by this guy named gary winick who uh who
worked for lucasfilm games was the
studio that turned into lucas arts
eventually uh
he designed this game there was a show
that was made out of it it only lasted
one episode
uh
basically it's the it's this
uh very tongue-in-cheek nuclear society
uh where everything runs on on nuclear
energy and retro futurism as well i kind
of think fallout owes a lot to this
because there's a ton of themes that
kind of like that bled into that uh
but yeah this very like post-war like
americana like
everything's great now that everything's
glowing kind of a kind of a approach to
this
uh there is a uh there's an evil villain
whose name is dr mayhem
who has created a soda pop that's
radioactive enough to make everybody
mutate
and the plan was to scare everybody out
of the city with it but it turned out
that it was delicious
so everyone just kind of left with the
tayden
yeah uh so there's just people walking
around like there's a kid with two heads
and his mom has an eyeball for a head
and his dad grows extra arms like the
evil villain who by the way was
originally voiced by uh christopher
walken and then the studio replaced him
last minute according to the creators
they wouldn't say why i'm assuming
because putting christopher walken into
like any children's media turns it into
an instant nightmare yeah that would be
my guess as well
mouse hunt
dr may how he he winds up taking a group
of nina it's gonna sound like i'm making
this up totally does there's a delivery
driver an electric company employee
there's a maintenance worker a dog
and a tool box and he takes them all
hostage
uh
why does he take a toolbox hostage
unclear okay
they're carrying a tool box oh they're
carrying tools he wasn't like he puts it
into
the cage with them
right and like
chains up the toolbox it really it's it
it's a terrific show they all wind up
getting coded in uh in the mutation soda
and electrocuted and they walk away with
crazy superpowers
one of them
jet headstrong is his name he gets the
power to shoot his head off of his body
like a rocket yep in what instance would
that be useful
for legs it's such a great shot a
toolbox becomes like a hammer like a a
hammer with a big a human's body
yeah becomes a sentient yeah has it has
a hammer for a hat
what does the dog do i gotta know what
the dog does
i think it's just
sort of basic crypto the super dog stuff
yeah it's it's not a i i was expecting
like its tail as a propeller and like i
don't know i i i thought it was gonna be
much weirder i could see why you would i
mean it only lasted for one episode so
assume they would have dealt with that
in episodes got it got it
was it cancelled makes perfect sense was
it canceled like halfway through the
airing like
probably it was uh it turned out
like it's 10 minutes in the network's
like
yeah
fox was kind of like right on the edge
of starting to do stuff like power
rangers like they were about to take all
the cheapest shortcuts that they could
like an original
animated program probably just wasn't up
there alley but they'd have this crazy
voice cast whoopi goldberg played one of
the main characters uh miss
miss mega what i can't remember her name
there was uh tim curry played one of the
bad guys
who was played by uh brian stokes
mitchell wow aka the teacher from ghost
dad
so there was a lot of good stuff going
on
let's not be talking about ghost dad
we don't talk about ghosts i know we've
been looking for a name for the show for
a while uh can we call it let's not talk
about ghost head yeah
perfect so that's your pick what would a
lot what would a cinematic universe of
defenders of dynatron city look like to
you
i think there's a ton of stuff you could
do with it i think that if you
approached it as like a tongue-in-cheek
mcu situation where you're giving all of
these stupid stupid characters their own
movies and tv shows like i would love a
buzzsaw for legs lady tv show like man
just 10 episodes of training
oh yeah oh yeah i would imagine having
buzz sauce for legs is not oh
thank you and no i i just think that
that's hilarious it's it's this it's
this weirdly
there's so much that you could do with
this universe it's so goofy and stupid
and uh i would i would love to see
somebody approach it just
full throttle what if
here's my final pitch before we go
what if somehow defenders of dinotron
city and bionx 6 were combined
because they kind of have a similar vibe
right they're both got that retro
futurism thing they both have weird
science going on they both have you know
the ability for tongue-in-cheek
wackiness to happen and they're
basically all superhero stories dealing
with
ridiculous villains and they've both
fallen into the public domain i'm
betting yeah probably i have one final
pitch
the b plot of that series is that there
are monsters living in the sewers
learning how to scare children
i love it i want it we could call it so
the cinematic universe yeah we could
call it the monsters
defenders of bionic city
[Laughter]
perfect perfect that's slickest nut they
all have to get together yeah yeah at
the end the monsters come out of the
sewers they save the day to help you
yeah yeah
they scare the villain away
yeah perfect one of them is frank and
beans thanks for watching please hit
like and subscribe so you don't miss a
single episode